[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 actualité idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le programme de
ce 13 mai avec la démission imminente du
gouvernement certains membres actuels ne
font pas partie du prochain remaniement
c'est le cas de nadia ministre délégué à
la ville qui est de nouveau candidate
pour être député dans les yvelines elle
s'apprête à quitter ses fonctions depuis
sa prise de poste en 2020 nous l'avons
rencontré samedi c'est le coup d'envoi
des journées nationales de la croix
rouge française elle se déroule jusqu'au
22 mai un rendez vous indispensable pour
faire vivre les activités locales de
l'association pourra parler martin de la
barre président de la délégation des
yvelines et sylvie perron n'est
responsable communication sont nos
invités et puis comme tous les vendredis
nos idées de sorties pour samedi et
dimanche dans les yvelines ce sera dans
la deuxième partie de cette émission est
pas de bixente mayence insisté ban avec
moi ce vendredi en plateau mais justin
brazy de la rédaction de tv 78 bonjour
justin moi je regarde comment ça va en
ce début de week-end c'est bientôt le
week-end c'est bientôt le week end we et
du coup dans cette partie loisirs on
parlera du fest harmonie qui revient
pour une deuxième édition cette fois ci
donc en présentiel un week end de
concerts d'orchestre et d'ensembles
musicaux et ça se passera à montigny on
accueillera d'ailleurs en plateau elle
demande de l'harmonie saint quentinois
qui organise cet événement oui parce que
votre mission si vous l'acceptez c'est
de donner l envie de sortir aux
yvelinois pour ce week-end pour samedi
et dimanche avec différentes activités
différentes idées de sorties à leur
proposer ce sera tout à l'heure dans le
sahtu ce week-end
on parle politique d'abord elle
s'apprête à quitter le gouvernement ne
vienne sera plus ministre délégué à la
ville après le prochain remaniement
prévu la semaine prochaine à quelques
heures de son départ elle nous a ouvert
les portes de son ministère en pleine
préparation de ses cartons le reportage
de nicolas landry et de michael et demi
d'euros donc ce que vous voyez là c'est
les affaires personnelles qu'il nous
reste encore à embarquer les livres
voilà il la bibliothèque accueille
qu'est en train de se vider derniers
jours non son ministère pour nadia est
nommé ministre délégué en charge de la
ville 6 juillet 2020 par jean castex
l'elvinoise né à traves a quitté
l'avenue de ségur la semaine prochaine
suite au remaniement ministériel
ça fait un peu bizarre mais en même
temps c'est le ccc la règle et donc
n'ont cessé dans une certaine continuité
évidemment de ce qui a été fait j'ai dû
faire mes cartons quand j'étais
parlementaire
beaucoup beaucoup moins de temps pour
prendre le poste et la fonction du
volume de du ministère de la ville donc
non c'est juste dans une continuité
évidemment sur le départ la femme
politique de 42 ans a participé à son
dernier conseil des ministres ce
mercredi 11 mai continuera à gérer les
dossiers présents sur sa table jusqu'à
la passation de pouvoir s'est vraiment
finir cette gestion courante et puis
surtout rester en alerte de tout ce qui
peut se passer puisque j'occupe ce poste
enfin cette fonction de ministre tant
que tant que la passion n'a pas été fait
donc il peut y avoir n'importe quel
alerte un dossier qui remonte urgemment
une décision à prendre aussi j'ai des
parapheurs sur mon bureau qui attend de
ma signature donc il ya encore des
choses qui qui se passe au sein du
ministère pendant un an et dix mois n'a
d'y être étaient des centaines de
dossiers dans un ministère qui pèse 550
millions d'euros pour la politique de la
ville et 12 milliards pour leur
rénovation urbaine ce qui lui tient à
coeur la place des femmes dans la
société
levin oiseaux notamment soutenu les
gilet rose une opération chiffrée à 2
millions d'euros ce sont ces femmes
courage qui interviennent dans les
quartiers qui parfois aussi résonne
certains jeunes quand il ya des
affrontements entre police et population
ce sont des femmes aussi qu'ils ont
décidé de se retrousser les manches pour
aider d'autres femmes qui sont victimes
de violences conjugales qui sont aussi
parfois en manque de repères une fois
parti de son ministre nadiana intra pas
pour autant la politique l'ancien député
sera de nouveau candidat dans son
département pour les prochaines
élections législatives en juin mais
cette fois ci dans un 7e circonscription
des yvelines
et d'autres actualités ont bien sûr
marqué la semaine illinois ce qu'il faut
retenir en 78 secondes avec matt ile de
france
[Musique]
la semaine a débuté avec la célébration
de la journée de l'europe une date qui
marque la signature de la déclaration
schuman texte pionnier de la
construction européenne rédigée dans les
yvelines à bazoches sur guyonne l'uaw a
résidé l'un des pères fondateurs jean
monnet l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et le cnrs ont
renouvelé leur partenariat pour 50 plus
un accord qui permet de développer la
recherche dans de nombreux domaines et
d'attirer des chercheurs d'excellence
saint-quentin-en-yvelines rend hommage à
simone veil pour marquer le cinquième
anniversaire de sa mort la bibliothèque
du canal a décidé de mettre à l'honneur
cette figure emblématique du combat des
femmes à travers une exposition jusqu'au
18 juin coup d'envoi du bac c'est la
première fois depuis la réforme que les
lycéens plancher sur leur nouvelle
épreuve de spécialité à cette occasion
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer s'est rendu dans un
lycée à marly-le-roi pour aller à leur
rencontre des élèves et des enseignants
la biennale d'architecturé du paysage
fait son grand retour à versailles
initié par la région ile-de-france cette
seconde édition est consacrée aux liens
entre la terre et les villes avec un
fort accent sur le développement durable
[Musique]
vous les verrez sans doute dans les rues
ces prochains jours du 14 au 22 mai les
bénévoles de la croix rouge seront sur
le terrain pour collecter des dons à
l'occasion des journées nationales de la
croix rouge pour parler de cet événement
en plateau avec moi et deux invités
martin de la barre bonjour bonjour
résidents de la délégation territoriale
des yvelines de la croix-rouge également
sylvie peyronnet bonjour bonjour
responsable communication pour la
croix-rouge des yvelines déjà une
première question pourquoi ce
rendez-vous est essentiel pour la croix
rouge c'est journée nationale alors
c'est assez c'est une journée
extrêmement forte parce que c'est la
journée enfin la journée la semaine qui
va nous permettre d'une part de récup dû
récolter des dons pour nos actions
locales c'est une semaine nous allons
aller à devant au devant des personnes
pour expliquer ce que nous faisons parce
que nous avons beaucoup d'action et
parfois méconnu donc c'est important
qu'on a eu lieu voilà et puis peut-être
pour autre chose sylvie je te donne la
parole puis aussi c'est l'occasion ou
jamais pour pour le nom pour les
habitants des yvelines de devenir
bénévole d'un jour parce que c'est
toujours des besoins bénévolement oui
toujours toujours et puis aussi c'est un
moyen de connaître la croix-rouge de
l'intérieur et aussi de relayer tous les
toutes les grandes valeurs humanitaires
de cette association et ô combien
combien important puisque nous avons
déjà mille sept cent mille sept cents
bénévoles
répartis sur tout le territoire des
yvelines je rappelle que nous avons 16
unités locales donc qui a forcément près
de chez vous une unité locale auquel
vous pouvez vous adresser et si vous
voulez vous être engagé et est allé dans
des actions beaucoup plus approfondie
sans problème il ya forcément une
mission pour vous il ya une implantation
qui est qui est bien présente dans les
yvelines de la croix rouge avec en plus
un contexte il faut le rappeler
de nombreuses urgences ont en ce moment
la précarité qui augmente
malheureusement depuis ces dernières
années il ya aussi eu la crise sanitaire
et la guerre en ukraine maintenant je
voudrais d'abord remercier les yvelinois
parce qu'ils ont été extrêmement
généreux
dans leurs dons dans leur vrai ment dans
leurs dons auprès de la croix-rouge pour
l'ukraine c'est vrai que la croix-rouge
et auxiliaires de l'état je vous le dis
à chaque fois mais c'est très important
donc quand il y à des urgences quand il
ya des déclenchements à cause de toutes
les catastrophes malheureusement qui
arrive la croix rousse comme les autres
associations de sécurité civile sont
déclenchés et on le retrouve partout sur
le territoire pour essayer d'aider d'eau
pour l'ukraine évidemment on a été aidé
mais justement je veux simplement dire
que là les journées dont nous allons
parler
l'argent on va dire les vraiment les
contributions des donateurs vont servir
localement lens sort de la crise de
l'ukraine localement nous on y est
toujours un vous inquiéter mais ces
journées sont spécifiquement locales et
en plus ce qui est important de rappeler
c'est que même un don le plus modestes
même avec un euro c'est un repas qui est
financé tout à fait tout à fait ça
faisait ça c'est importe c'est important
de le dire
4 5 euros c'est déjà un kit un kit
d'hygiène c'est 20 20 euros c'est aussi
la possibilité
effectivement de d'offrir une
consultation médicale à ceux qui n'ont
pas accès effectivement en remboursement
de la sécurité sociale
mais c'est aussi 60 euros c'est le moyen
aussi de faire des formations de
bénévoles pour aider
pour aider et à toutes les actions
vis-à-vis des ce qui effectivement sont
touchés par les maladies d'alzheimer par
exemple un par exemple et ces journées
nationales elles seront lancées donc
officiellement ce samedi 14 mai avec
deux ambassadeurs qu'on connaît très
bien de rihanna karembeu et et marqués
lille ce sera dans quatre villes de
france à paris dijon nice et rennes dont
les insa va s'organiser comment alors
d'abord j'espère que l'an prochain nous
les aurons avec nous déjà passé par dix
alors commencé à faire des jeux veulent
aussi moi j'avais le et d'autres
d'autres célébrités de des yvelines à
nous revient à nous représenter un
devenir nos parrains pour nos prochaines
journées j'attends un appel est lancé
venez me contacter et vous savez il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire dans les
yvelines notamment auprès de nos jeunes
qui sont très impliqués dans ces actions
je rappelle que si une des premières
missions que nous lançons de plus en est
de plus en plus fortement auprès auprès
des populations c'est prévenir éduquer
oui ça c'est là c'est la première c'est
là une des premières grandes missions
que je dirais historique puisque nous
avons toujours fait de la promotion de
la prévention et de et de la formation
en matière de secourisme certes mais
aussi maintenant c'est l'ouverture sur
la formation au droit humanitaire aux
valeurs humanitaires etc ô combien par
ces temps incertains par ces temps
bousculé ou aude et désoriente
désorienté il est important d'accentuer
sur ses valeurs alors là nous avons fait
en particulier le droit international
humanitaire que nous nous formons nous
nous racontons nous expliquons nous
formons les étudiants les élèves au
droit international humanitaire et à
tout ce qui est éducation humanitaire
dans son sens large donc ça c'est une
nouvelle mission cette mission
particulièrement est très importante va
nous demander beaucoup de bénévoles de
temps et de moyens donc on en revient
toujours au moyen pour aller partout
dans les écoles la croix rouge a signé
une convention avec l'éducation
nationale et grâce à cette convention
nous ont travaillé avec les étudiants et
les scolaires et il il crée le relance
nous allons les options rouge dans
certains collèges des lycées doit
absolument par exemple la wii on a vu le
pecq enfin il ya beaucoup de conventions
qui ont qui vont être se dérouler
pendant l'année scolaire 2022 22000 23
on avait confiance un tonneau rhino si
notre actualité on sait de la
croix-rouge aussi est présente sur les
grands événements forcément les jo sont
dans un coin de votre tête j'imagine
aussi la peinture que oui wind est en
ordre de marche on se met en ordre de
marche effectivement vous prêt pour
préparer ces cjo parce que effectivement
nous allons être dans les yvelines en
première ligne puisque nous avons
beaucoup d'épreuves qui se déroule sur
notre territoire je parle du golf par
exemple
l'équipe de vivre que si on sait pas
encore comment ça va s'organiser c'est
dans un moteur tombe on l'a compris donc
saison mais la sauvage 2002 ou en
revanche nos dispositifs de prévention
que nous avons avec les secouristes
partout dans les communes des yvelines
quand vous avez un spectacle il ne fait
une brocante évidemment nous sommes
présents pour les dispositifs de
de secours
pour paris versailles voilà que nous
l'accompagnons ans et voilà les fêtes
des loges on nous y sommes aussi c'est à
sa demande et des dons j'ai fait rien et
on en revient au jour est alors très
rapidement parce qu'on dépasse le temps
comment on peut aider la croix rouge
quelles sont les différentes façons de
donner
d'abord c'est de rencontrer nos
bénévoles dans soit dans les marchés
ces week-ends vont être l'avant être à
propos pour effectivement nous
rencontrer donc nous aurons nous avons
la jaquette et puis les trente questions
qui seront qui sont effectivement
qui seront mis à la disposition du
public mais aussi on peut on peut donner
par sms un os 92200 fait les
informations s'affichent
dans 78 c'est aussi c'est aussi simple
que ça c'est 5,5 euros mais qu'on peut
renouveler si on en veut puis aussi
c'est directement sur notre sur notre
site je donne je donne
je suis actuellement suis désolé on
arrive déjà la fin de cet entretien on
retrouve toutes les informations pour
pouvoir résister d'accord nous contacter
voilà la délégation territoriale et à
disposition de tout le monde et sera sur
le terrain pour ces journées nationales
qui vont se dérouler jusqu'au 22 mai
merci martine de la barre merci sylvie
ferro belle d'être venu en parler en
plateau merci le retour à présent d'une
rubrique dans le sahtu ce week-end c'est
légal checking le décryptage des petites
phrases de l'actualité avec le collectif
des surligneurs aujourd'hui focus sur
une règle et de l'union européenne
évoqué récemment dans un tweet de jean
luc mélenchon c'est avec raphaël mata
duvignau
avec beaucoup d'ironie jean luc
mélenchon a rappelé à clément beau le
secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes
la nécessité de respecter la règle des
3% de déficit sans quoi il y avait
désobéi sens l union européenne il
estime ainsi que la france comme
d'autres pays de l'union désobéissent
déjà aux règles communautaires
en réalité jean luc mélenchon confond
dérogations accordées qui est légal et
désobéissance qui ne l'est pas pour
rappel afin de ne pas déstabiliser
l'euro les états membres de l'union
européenne doivent respecter les
critères du pacte de stabilité de
croissance dont l'objectif est justement
d'assurer la stabilité des prix et la
croissance économique en coordonnant
leurs politiques publiques budgétaire à
ce titre un arsenal de règle a été
adoptée parmi lesquels notamment la
fameuse règle des 3% c'est-à-dire
l'exigence pour un état membre de
maintenir son déficit public annuel à
moins de 3% de son pib jean luc
mélenchon en déduit donc que la france
devrait revenir dans le prochain budget
à 3% de déficit si le gouvernement
actuel ne voulait pas désobéir à l'union
européenne on aura compris le message à
peine subliminal de la france insoumise
ne nous reprochez pas de vouloir
désobéir alors que vous le faites vous
même mais en réalité jean luc mélenchon
aignan un élément important en raison de
la crise sanitaire depuis 2020 et
jusqu'au 1er janvier 2023 a été activé
la clause dérogatoire général du pacte
de stabilité qui confère donc aux états
membres plus de souplesse en raison des
circonstances extraordinaires et
indépendantes de la volonté des
gouvernements les règles de discipline
budgétaire tel que l'exigence de
maintenir le déficit en dessous de 3%
sont en ce moment suspendue pour
permettre aux états membres de
consolider leur économie en raison de la
crise sanitaire c'est donc l'arroseur
arrosé et on rappellera la toute fin
utile que lorsqu'un gouvernement désobéi
aux normes existantes au mieux c'est une
illégalité au pire c'est de l'arbitraire
et aucun juge européen ou national nous
peut laisser faire
bon
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week end
justin brasier de nouveau là pour sa
sélection des idées de sorties du
week-end et on commence justement ce
week-end en musique exactement puisque
l'harmonie saint quentin en yvelines qui
est avec nous organise la deuxième
édition du fest harmonie le festival va
réunir une dizaine d'orchestre et
d'ensembles à montigny le bretonneux ce
sera à des concerts les 14 et 15 mai et
donc vous êtes avec nous ou jules brunel
saxophoniste et francis pas là marzouk
chef d'orchestre et vous êtes tous les
deux donc je vais me le dire de
l'harmonie de saint quentin en yvelines
merci d'être avec nous
bonjour bonjour
première question pourquoi ce festival
d'orchestre d'harmonie aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'était un manque peut-être
sur le territoire
il ya beaucoup d'orchestrés avant
répartis sur le territoire français
d'ailleurs la musique
d'harmonie est né en france et par
contre dans la région parisienne on a
beaucoup moins
et quand j'ai créé cette association il
ya maintenant 23 ans c'était pour
diffuser ce répertoire
qui fait partie de notre patrimoine on a
créé cet ensemble on était douze
musiciens maintenant on est 50 2 et on
veut évidemment populariser cette chose
qui nous appartient qui appartient à la
france
en proposant évidemment plusieurs pièces
qui populaire et où gît sa vente pour
faire découvrir cette belle musique à
tout le monde
et donc
avec les amateurs de la région de saint
quentin en yvelines
on les fait se rencontrer puis on a plus
on est pleinement de moins que son sol
en temps surtout dans ce territoire là
et avec un concert avec leur classe de
l'armée de l'air qui sont professionnels
qui font partie des meilleurs phalange
française qui permet aux musiciens de
voir jusqu'où on peut aller au public de
voir jusqu'où on peut aller en qualité
d'une grande qualité
réputé sur plan national et même
international avec cet orchestre est
donc ça c'est l'objectif c'est un peu de
faire se rencontrer vous l'avez dit il y
avait déjà une première édition avant la
question des terres là la deuxième
édition peut enfin se tenir puisqu'elle
n'avait pas eu lieu à cause justement de
la crise sanitaire qu'est ce que ça vous
fait ça nous fait quand même un grand
plaisir de d'enfin aboutir ce projet
après plus de deux ans d'attentes et
aussi de réunir d'avoir la chance de
réunir plusieurs harmonies aussi une
banda et à un big band et d'avoir le
privilège baisse pour le samedi soir
d'avoir la musique de l'air et pour
clôturer les sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines donc ça devrait être un
phénomène d'une bonne ampleur surtout
fait à la ferme du mas n'est
justement on a dit ça rassemble
plusieurs harmonies à plusieurs
ensembles locaux de sky notamment des
donc justement des acteurs locaux du
territoire c'est important de donner
cette visibilité justement aux acteurs
locaux du territoire oui
dans la région parisienne justement jeu
j'ai envie aussi que des gens
participent dans la vie de leurs droits
dans l'endroit où ils vivent c'est très
important que sur ce point cela ne soit
pas tout temps boulot métro dodo mais
que des gens soient heureux de vivre ça
corresponde quelque part à la maxime de
montigny-le-bretonneux la ville qui vous
va bien ou saint quentin en yvelines on
va dire de territoire qui vous va bien
que tout le monde soit content de
participer dans le dans leur commune et
apporte quelque chose en plus vous avez
parlé de plusieurs temps forts déjà là
on va en revenir on va y revenir pardon
dans quelques instants au niveau du
programme donc il est disponible en
ligne 1 / rock / notamment le site de
montigny le bretonneux il y aura
également par exemple l'harmonie de
maurepas celle de magny les hameaux ou
encore l'orchestré départemental des
sapeurs pompiers des yvelines ce sera
dimanche pour clôturer le festival tout
ça est disponible en ligne et dans
plusieurs lieux de la ville de montigny
le bretonneux conservatoire des arts le
pavé du canal l'assaut de riz et puis à
la ferme du manet ou aura lieu justement
votre concert et donc je vais revenir là
dessus puisque nous sommes allés
assister hier donc ce jeudi 12 mai à
votre dernière répétition avant cette
estivale je vous propose de découvrir
les images de michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
elle existe depuis plus de 20 ans
l'harmonie de saint quentin en yvelines
se produira aux festayres money ce
week-end du 14 et 15 mai pour sa
deuxième édition une dizaine de concerts
sont prévus à montigny le bretonneux au
départ les membres de l'ensemble de sky
n'étaient que 12 c'était il ya plus de
vingt ans aujourd'hui saxophoniste
flûtiste et clarinettiste ils sont près
de quarante musiciens à faire partie de
l'harmonie chacun a son vol quand on a
les instruments qui sont dans les graves
c'est d'apporter la stabilité de
l'orchestré ne donnait le tempo de
permettre de liquider et puis tu en
entends l'instrument il est soliste
effectivement selon les passages les
compositions l'ensemble se réunit deux
heures tous les jeudis des rendez vous
collectif important pour caler les
musiques ont travaillé chacun chez soi
et donc le rythme tout ça c'est se fait
au rythme particulier qui nous est
propre et qui nous permet de jouer
facilement mais quand on est dans
l'ensemble faut poursuivre notre chef et
là ça se complique donc d'où l'intérêt
de faire des répétitions des répétitions
à quelques heures du début du festival
les membres de l'harmonie peaufiner les
derniers détails
c'est à dire que le feriez
faire et demi à la majeure 3 par exemple
je vais faire un peu plus on a tous
réunis et donc on va c'est un peu une
générale on va répéter tous les morceaux
dans l'ordre mal détail si on fait aussi
l'enchaînement on fait aussi ce qu'on
appelle une générale donc là c'est le
cas
et on essaye de travailler les nuances
et puis la justesse aussi il ya des
hauts et des bas ben ce qui compte c'est
qu'on progresse trousses ensemble vers
plus de qualité justement pour le
festival le répertoire sera varié du
jazz au classique en passant dans la
variété mais aussi des musiques de films
en 3d sur le chemin avec les trains le
train train quotidien qui va changer
quoi on va être dans donc jacobites
express et le petit 5 plaisir voilà
rendez vous samedi 14 mai à la salle du
manet de montigny le bretonneux pour
découvrir ce répertoire
et on continue donc justin a parlé de
cet événement avec une dernière question
peut-être pour no 1 vitesse oui une
dernière question notamment sur un des
temps forts on en a parlé d'autres tout
à l'heure mais il y aura le trophée des
harmonies dimanche ce sera pas un
concert et avec la sig de ce que j'ai
compris mais un rendez vous qui sera
sous forme de battle avec différents
ensembles harmonie comment ça va se
passer concrètement les harmonies vont
passer une par une ça va commencer par
par exemple mon équilibre teneur ensuite
on va enchaîner avec l'harmonie de saint
cyr est terminée par saint rémy les
chevreuse après le jury va débattre
après écoute dont notre chef est dans le
membre du jury ben ils sont jugés par
rapport aux bains aux nuances par
rapport à la musicalité et beaucoup
d'autres éléments qui puissent faire à
part aller un petit peu les membres du
jury et ensuite selon
le débat qu'ils ont donné à la fin il ya
une chaque harmonie roja la récompense
c'est à dire un le précieux trophée des
harmonies plus une récompense en plus
dont jeune je ne dirai pas plus papa
c'est un mystère c'est une surprise à
découvrir
c'est tellement il me rappelle un votre
votre concert à vous ce sera à samedi 14
à 20 h 30 à la ferme du manet trier
réservations sont disponibles en lingala
pas merci à nos deux invités d'être venu
en parler bonbons événement avoue un qui
revient après des temps de crise
sanitaire direction à villepreux justin
à présent avec un événement annuel qui a
débuté ce vendredi oui ce 13 mai et ce
sera jusqu'au 21 ailleurs la ville de
villepreux a lancé son annuel semaine du
développement durable l'objectif c'est
mieux faire connaître les thématiques
mais aussi sensibiliser c'est une
nouvelle édition qui se veut festive
mais surtout aussi pédagogique à
laurence morel le son maire adjointe
chargée de l'environnement du
développement et de l'agriculture à
villepreux nous dévoile le programme
[Musique]
il ya toujours une grande conférence
cette année on a la présence assez
unique d'un chef multi étoilé qui en
plus a été prise hier pendant des années
on a aussi
à une soirée ciné débat cette année donc
on a choisi de de montrer le film hors
norme on a aussi le village des
mobilités
[Musique]
on a une grande exposition artistique
qu'on a appelé avec humour tout belle la
vie il y aura aussi ça c'est inédit pour
ponctuer la fin de cette séquence une
belle séance au théâtre avec des matchs
d'improvisation avec des équipes
internationales
[Musique]
c'est évidemment une
incitation de la mairie comment dire à
apporter un regard sur les producteurs
de proximité pour essayer de d'acide
acheter au plus près pour ici et essayer
d'inciter les huit revient à améliorer
leur bilan carbone par exemple le
village des mobilités dont je parlais
c'est évidemment au delà de l'aspect
festif de la parade vélo c'est
évidemment pour inciter là aussi les
villes provient à faire le choix des
mobilités douces quand ils le peuvent
un guide agricole avec les coordonnées
donc des producteurs locaux de
villepreux sera distribué sur place et
lundi 16 mai le conseil municipal
présentera dans le cadre donc de cette
semaine son rapport annuel du
développement durable pour la ville de
programme complet est à retrouver sur le
site de la ville d'autres idées de
sorties à présent justin dans cette
émission du sport et une rencontre à ne
pas manquer ce week-end et oui le
football club de versailles reçoit à
plabennec ce sera ce samedi à 18 heures
pour la 28e journée de nationale 2 ce
sera une fête au stade mont boron
puisque ce sera la première fois que les
yvelinoises joues rondes pour l'heure
publique depuis la validation de leur
montée dans le championnat de national
3e échelon à 10 football français et
c'est une rencontre à enjeu car en cas
de victoire versailles s'assurer le
titre de champion du groupe à de
nationale 2 une joie de plus dans une
saison exceptionnelle où l'équipe a
atteint également les demi finales de la
coupe de france a pu suivre toutes ces
joies versaillaise on est à versailles
après l'effort du réconfort exactement
direction avenue de paris derrière
l'ancienne poste pour le retour de la
guinguette éphémère à le grand opening
c'est ce week end au programme à 10
djebbar food truck gospel mais encore
quiz une idée pour ceux qui veulent se
poser autour d'un verre après le match
manger un morceau où se dépenser à sur
la piste de danse si la guinguette et
éphémère pas d'inquiétude elle restera
en place jusqu'au 17 juillet mais à
maurepas ou fête son anniversaire et oui
celui des serres municipales de la ville
qui fêtent leurs 30 ans est la ville
vous invite pour l'occasion à son annuel
manifestation qui revient en présentiel
cette année le mes desserts s'invite à
table ça se passe les 14 et 15 mai de 9h
à 18h à l'est un march bout au programme
à distribution de bulbes et de papier en
semences et ateliers bouturer en potage
ou encore conférence sur les abeilles et
permaculture il y en aura pour tous les
goûts les informations et programme
complet sur le site de la ville les
dernières idées de sorties à montigny le
bretonneux oui puisque dimanche 15 mai
pour y aura un marché du terroir une
première édition qui prendra place sur
le parvis de l'hôtel de ville de 10
heures à 18 heures près de trente
exposants seront sur place pour
présenter leurs produits locaux
régionaux il y aura également de
l'artisanat et des produits cosmétiques
donc c'est un marché pour valoriser le
circuit court est des animations
ponctueront la journée avec musique
danse ferme pédagogique mais aussi un
défi sportif comme le vélo smoothies et
je vous rappelle aussi que samedi c'est
la dix huitième nuit européenne des
musées avec de nombreux sites qui sont
ouverts dans les yvelines pour connaître
le programme je vous renvoie à notre
édition du 7 8 journal du 5 mai ou le
site internet on devait clôturer cette
émission justin en parlant d'un concert
qui variait m'ont encore un peu de temps
pourra parler puisque ce concert aura
lieu le il me semble du côté de thoiry
avec un concert de yannick noah mais on
aura l'occasion de vous en reparler dans
nos prochaines éditions du 7 8 week-end
qui touche déjà à sa fin merci justin
d'avoir été avec moi sur ce plateau bon
week-end à vous et vous revenez quand
vous voulez
écouter l'invitation est prise et elle
est allée donner on verra si vous
revenez l'intenable aya par michel
temman sortie stepan va revenir aussi
dans ce set 8 week end c'est la fin de
cette émission la fois sur le calme
revient dès lundi sur tv soixante dix
huit avec le journal de la rédaction à
18 heures et d'ici là bien sûr passer un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]